the death of a young Iranian woman in
police custody has sparked weeks of
violent protest in Iran and around the
world the UN an independent human rights
groups have accused Iranian security
forces of brutal suppression where does
that leave attempts to restart the 2015
nuclear deal which the U.S says is no
longer their focus Mohammed mirandi
professor at Tehran University and
political analyst but we all know that
the whole process is politicized but the
Iranians are more than willing to solve
the issue if the Americans are
determined to have a deal Dr mirandi
blames the Western NATO for aggravating
the protests and a whole catalog of
aggression against Iran and other
countries in the region and as Tehran
denies supplying drones to Moscow whose
side does he take in the ukraine-russia
war
[Music]
Muhammad marandi welcome to conflict
Zone a couple of weeks ago you tried to
minimize the importance of the whole
protest movement in Iran you said it had
died down after three or four days and
that wasn't true was it because two days
ago and six weeks since they began the
protests were reported in at least Seven
Cities including mashad arak zahidan
mahabad
and parts of Tehran they're not dying
down at all are they no I didn't try to
do anything I said the truth the protest
in the first couple of days were larger
and they were in different cities and
they were partially because a Persian
language media in London mostly but also
in other Western countries lied at the
very beginning and they claimed that the
young lady Masa was beaten to death and
so many people thought that this was a
case of police brutality I also thought
that that may have been the case but
then later on later on the footage came
out and it showed that she had left the
police van she wasn't even handcuffed
she wasn't holding her head she didn't
show any signs of physical pain she went
into a hall and sat there and after a
while she stood up spoke to someone and
then suddenly collapsed the autopsy
showed there are many physics positions
involved that there was no physical
abuse and even there's a clip of her
father
beside her body where he said that
there's no sign of abuse so
Persian language media funded by Western
governments and the Saudis many of them
based in London were provoking the
Iranian public but after a few days the
protests died down but then we had the
rise of very violent riots and that's
exactly what I said well let's talk
about the the violence in the riots the
U.N committee has had U.N committee on
the rights of the child has had plenty
to say about that it strongly condemned
what it called grave violations of
children's rights in Iran according to
Reliable Reports it says some children
were shot with live ammunition others
died as a result of beatings many
families reported that despite grieving
for the loss of a child they were
pressured to absolve Security Forces by
declaring their children had committed
suicide and making false confessions
that's a pretty sick tactic for your
government to employ isn't it
no that's a pretty sick tactic for the
Western media and any institutions that
are on the under the influence of the
western media to use we're talking about
the U.S committee on the rights of the
child
we're talking about a U.N committee
let's not reporting that let's let Tim
let's not talk about any un committee
let's talk about the U.N and how they
put the Saudis on a blacklist and
removed them 72 hours later the U.N has
no credibility here and this is this is
fake the the the claims to I I've
tweeted about this the the number of
police officers that were murdered over
the last few weeks at the instigation of
media based in your countries
they are they're roughly 28 or 29 some
of them were shot with guns don't talk
let's not talk about fake news all these
young children being killed all over the
place that's nonsense show me the
footage
why is it nonsense instead of these
organizations that are funded by the
United States why why is it nonsense
here's an organization here's an
organization that won't be funded by the
United States this last weekend the
coordinating Council of teachers in Iran
called for a nationwide strike to
protest the Crackdown on children that
same teachers organization said plain
close police attacked the Shah head
School in the Northwest adabil Province
ten pupils were injured badly enough to
be hospitalized parents of the children
were also attacked you really think that
your government going after children and
killing unknown numbers of demonstrators
is going to stop this unrest
so you're withdrawing the fake claim it
was killed at that school right I'm not
withdrawing anything because I'm in the
western media that couldn't make the
Western media the claim in the the claim
in the western media the filthy claim in
the western media and the filthy claim
in the Persian language media funded by
your government your government was that
a girl was murdered at that school and
then it turned out that that girl didn't
even go to that school and she died
because of a family tragedy but your
governments and those Iranian organizer
or so-called Iranian organizations
funded by your government in the west
make such fake claims so that the global
public opinion would turn against Iran
and they make those claims in Iran
because you have more Persian language
media
directly towards Iranians and the
Iranian government has so when your MEK
terrorist organization that's based in
Europe and has a huge camp in Albania
with thousands of people being acting as
trolls there day in these people they
fought alongside Saddam Hussein against
their own country they killed 17 000
Iranians during the 1980s through
assassination attacks through bomb
attacks these are the people who are
spreading alongside them
I noticed
I notice you don't want to address the
violence
um and the violence which and the
brutality of some of your security
forces Amnesty International
Amnesty International has reported
widespread torture severe beatings of
protesters and onlookers even sexual
violence against women by your security
forces you think that people will
forgive their leaders for this shocking
brutality okay
no people will not forgive your leaders
for interfering in our Internal Affairs
and foreign
language media I'm speaking Tim I'm
speaking don't try to run out the clock
so it's your Persian language media and
your troll farms and your governments
that are spreading misinformation both
in Persian and in English across the
globe the the police officers that were
killed in Iran 28 or 29 police officers
as far as I know during that period were
killed people who were policing the
streets if it if such numbers were
killed in your country what would be the
response of your government but what
what your Persian language media was
doing during this period was encouraging
people rioters to attack the police to
get revenge as they called it on police
they were telling people to make molotov
cocktails if off com if this if any of
this was in English and if it was
directed to an English audience of com
would shut down those TV stations within
minutes but in your case you can use it
against Iran because your governments
are Waging War against the Iranian
people your governments don't give a
damn about human rights your governments
are the ones who impose maximum pressure
on women and children in this country
and try to starve them to death and then
use media Warfare against the country to
create divisions Dr Miranda Dr Morandi
talk of running out of the clock
um I've given you a couple of minutes
two three minutes isn't it time to face
facts that Iranians and a lot of you're
interviewing me Iranians are angry at
your government the head of Iran's
semi-official iSpa polling Center Medi
bahabadi says a considerable majority of
Iranians Harbor anger towards the
Islamic Republic a factor he says which
is at a dangerous level every time
they've been widespread protests they
subside only super officially while the
anger piles up none of this is going
away is it none of this is going away
and you say it's all the West's fault
come on Tim we have we have many polling
institutions in Iran and Western polling
institutions
and the popular legitimacy of the
Islamic Republic of Iran is second to
none in this region your despotic allies
in this region tell more than enough
about your governments
in Iran just three years ago less than
three years ago after your
leader you're the leader of the
so-called free world murder General
suleimani we saw how many millions of
people went to the streets in Tehran so
let's not pretend that the truth is
anything that it is let's let's speak
facts of course there's dissatisfaction
in Iran there's always this fat exact
dissatisfaction in Iran you can go in a
taxi now five years ago 10 years ago you
can spend your time in Tehran that's
exactly the fact that it shows the fact
that in Iran people can speak their
minds but can they do that in Saudi
Arabia can they do that in many other
parts of the world can people like me
to easily do that and get a job in your
government or in your country why do you
keep putting it out why do you play the
what about game what about in Britain
what about Saudi Arabia why don't we
just stay with Iran is that so difficult
no I'm talking about you I'm talking
about you yeah we're not here to discuss
that use chemical weapons
oh yes we are because you have no
credibility
you you do you work for the the German
government funds your channel you think
the German government yes you think
you're right German government
on the international stage really these
protests that you said died down have
now spread to the culture they're spread
to actors broadcasters singers
people who are admired followed and have
nothing to do with politics
brought up and incited by the way we're
not in our league you're not in our
league don't run out the [ __ ] Tim you're
not in our league your government the
government that funds you that gives you
the opportunities to speak to me your
government
gassed me twice where where were you you
were working at the BBC back then you
were in your 30s when I was gassed twice
where were you when they were gassing
don't talk about credibility you don't
have credibility your television station
doesn't have credibility your government
doesn't have credibility in the European
Union doesn't have credibility so don't
talk down to Iran you like Joseph Borel
you take care of your garden and we'll
live in our jungle you're entitled to
your views Dr marandi but even among
your own politicians we're seeing the
first signs of open dissent over the
government's methods with these
demonstrations former speaker of
parliamentary larijani questioning the
use of force saying the police should
not be used to encourage the wearing of
the hijab he's calling for a cultural
solution Iranian Society he said needs
more tolerance don't you agree with that
so you're admitting that in Iran we have
open debate so you're admitting that we
have all sorts of voices in Iran so
you're admitting that we have different
people who argue with Iran and fight
with each other in Parliament outside of
parliament in government at universities
yes that is a part of Iran and that has
always been a part of Iran
post-revolution not pre-revolution when
your guys were in charge but
post-revolution in fact and this is
something that will continue but you can
continue as you have been as your
colleagues have been as Western media
has been saying for the last four years
that the Islamic Republic of Iran is
about to implode it is corrupt it is
unpopular people hate it it's collapsing
of course IRA and paradoxically it's
also a growing Menace I don't know how
how you can have both at the same time
whether it's on the one hand it's
unpopular it's hated and it's collapsing
but on the other hand it's a growing
Menace and a growing threat to the world
but for four decades now Iran has been
about to collapse and I think for the
next four decades we're going to be
hearing the same wishful thinking in the
western media and Western think tanks
again but let me try putting the
question again don't you think Iranian
Society needs more tolerance it's that
simple
can I have an answer
Iranian Society Iranian Society always
needs more tolerant Iranian society that
needs better government management
Iranian Society always deserves better
and that's what we have to strive to do
and so does your society and your
Society needs more tolerance in your
Society should show up and your
government should show a bit of humility
and apologize for the crimes that it is
committed to my people and people like
yourself should show more tolerance and
have a more open mind about those of us
who live in the jungle
oh please as Boral says oh please don't
don't take the moral High Ground when
your government is supporting Basha
al-assad in Syria oh I have them one of
the biggest killers and torturers in the
Middle East please don't please please
please don't take the moral High Ground
Dr Morandi I think you'll find that's
difficult your revolutionary God I will
oh revolutionary when you dismissed
I put a question to you could I put a
question to you your revolutionary guard
does this you already did all the
protests as sedition Major General
Hussain salami the Sedition will be a
stillborn baby and will go down in
history as a disgrace for America how
helpful do you think that is in trying
to address legitimate grievances of
people
don't make a point and then change the
topic so you can get away with it your
government NATO supported Al-Qaeda
in 2011 and 12 when I went to the
Western media and said that al-qa
Al-Qaeda is fighting it's here he said
they said these are conspiracy theories
this is nonsense well later on we saw
Wikileaks whose head is now in jail the
most famous political prisoner in the
world in in London
Wikileaks said that according to Jake
Sullivan the current national U.S
national security adviser he sent an
email to Hillary Clinton the head of the
state department at that time that in
Syria Al-Qaeda is on our side no it's
your government and your government said
the worst murderers in human history and
in contemporary history then we have the
U.S defense intelligence agency document
of 2012 we set a salafis entity Regional
countries Allied to the United States
are trying to create a salafist entity
between Syria and Iraq well who what is
that what was that entity it was Isis
and then General Flynn at that time said
that the that they were determined and
the United States allowed for that
entity
they're answering you're really not
interested
in answering any questions let me finish
let me finish this is not a lecture no
let me finish I asked you soon
said in a private conversation you're
afraid
you're afraid one time you're afraid
questions come on ask your question my
my question you're afraid my question
Terry said we let Isis Advance on
Damascus
there could have been a different
approach by the government to this
unrest couldn't there like the ones
suggested by five leading Iranian
economists earlier this month who say
the authorities should listen to the
demonstrators and prepare for
fundamental change is there anybody
inside the government who is preparing
for fundamental change in your view
first of all when in going back to the
previous question the guards and whoever
and anyone else who spoke about sedition
they were not talking about protesters
so don't try to twist their words they
were talking about those groups that are
funded by the United States in Iraqi
Kurdistan
that they have military camps there and
they carry out operations in Iran
they're talking about those
organizations alongside the no man's
land in Pakistan baluchistan that fund
are funded by your government or the
United States and its allies and Carry
Out operations in Iran they're talking
about those MEK terrorists that your
governments allowed to function across
Europe that have killed many thousands
of Iranians and acted as foot soldiers
for Saddam Hussein who are active in
Iran by their own and own admission so
they're talking about that sedition so
all right all right
you've had your cigars and others you've
flung around all the accusations you
haven't provided any evidence at all
let's talk if we may about the nuclear
issue because you've been an advisor to
the government on the nuclear issue in
your view is this the end of the road
for negotiations we have the U.S saying
that they simply don't believe believe
that Iran is prepared to do what's
necessary to make the deal happen
in your view is that the end of the road
for the negotiations
well the
well Tim
who left the deal
who violated the deal Obama violated the
deal when Iran was carrying out all of
its commitments then Trump tore up the
deal when Iran was carrying out all its
commitments then Biden continued to
pursue Trump's policies so it wasn't
Iran's fault Iran began negotiating to
make sure the loopholes that existed
that that existed in the past after 2015
were removed so the the United States
could not cheat Iran again they
negotiated hard gained many concessions
finally on the last day of negotiations
in Vienna the EU gave a text that met a
lot of Iran's key demands and the
Iranians took it home they gave their
uh ideas about some of the problems that
need to be resolved and Joseph borell
admitted the U.S Ally Joseph Burrell
admitted that the Iranian demands were
reasonable we thought at that time we
had a deal
but the United States delayed and then
gave a response that was obviously
intended to push things back probably we
thought back then because of the
November elections so the problem is not
the United States and by the way Iran at
the European the Europeans and Americans
were constantly saying that it's almost
too late the Iranian nuclear program is
crossing a threshold Beyond this
particular date we can no longer
continue negotiations but they're all
gone now what happened it was obvious
they were lying they knew that he wanted
some Modern programs knew that Iran was
not developing a bomb but it was all
psychological warfare the U.N says
you've still not provided credible
explanations for the presence of uranium
at three locations that were never
declared and you just say it's time to
close the false file do you enjoy
playing these kind of games with the
International Community
well Tim first of all it's not the
International Community it's Western
countries you are not the International
Community Your Guardian is only a small
part of the International Community
the Iranians have said that we are
prepared to respond to all of the
questions but the problem is that the
IAA and that's the iaea has a Board of
Governors that is dominated by Western
countries and the head of the iaea is
someone that's always in the western
Camp the previous head of the IAA when
he wanted to get elected and let's go
back to WikiLeaks according to WikiLeaks
documents he told the Americans if you
put me in power I will be in your camp
on all major issues so the Iranians are
saying take away the politics and bring
in the technical experts and the and the
issues can easily be resolved these
issues that you're claiming were given
by this really regime to the IAA and
these issues go back 20 some years ago
when the Iranian nuclear program was
taking baby steps it was nothing
compared to what it was today what it is
today so we all know that the whole
process is politicized but the Iranians
are more than willing to solve the issue
if the Americans are determined to have
a deal
you said you were asked why Iran is
enriching uranium at 60 levels what the
iae said levels that are reached only by
countries that are making nuclear bombs
and you say Iran does that in order to
get leverage in the talks
let's call that what it really is it's
not leverage it's a threat yes pure and
simple it's a threat isn't it pure and
simple if you don't get what you want
you'll build a bomb despite all the
assurances that you've given that you
don't intend to do that
no Tim you know do you know what a
threat is a threat is when your
government say all options are on the
table
a threat is when your country's your
government threaten to kill our people
that's a threat enriching at sixty
percent is leverage what your
governments to are threats and they
carry it out in different countries they
destroyed Iraq they destroyed Libya they
sanction Venezuela your government
steals money from the Venezuelan people
and starves them and then says the
government in Venezuela they mismanage
so you strangle people and then you ask
why can't they breathe no your
government threatens other countries and
your governments carry out those threats
so we take those seriously but no yeah
they're only saying it to tell the
Europeans and Americans to sit down and
get serious
harassing our people for over a hundred
years always always much conscious not
everyone else it's Western Government
it's always something it's not Asian it
is not Asia it is not Latin America it
is not Africa it is
NATO government don't pretend that
you're the international community
much controversy briefly over the last
few days
about the reports of Iranian drones
being used by Russia and its war with
Ukraine strenuous denials from Iranian
officials but the ukrainians themselves
have identified the devices as Shahid
136 drones how ignorant does Iran think
the rest of the world really is to try
and claim that they didn't give them to
Russia
don't don't don't don't don't call
yourself the rest of the world I'm I'm
first of all I'm not in the foreign
Ministry but a number of things Tim
and I and I speak on behalf of myself
your government's lied
you Advanced westwards you Advanced NATO
eastwards to the Russian border your
government carried out a coup in Ukraine
your government supported right-wing
fascists like the azov Battalion which
in the western media it was discussed
they were saying before the events this
year that they that this is a big
problem in Ukraine and they killed 15 or
15 or 16 000 ethnic Russians in the
donbass region and in other parts of
eastern Ukraine your governments
provoked Russia your government allowed
this to happen you've gone through the
list and you've swallowed Russian
propaganda Hook Line and Sinker Dr
mirandi it's been good to have you on
conflict Zone thank you very much yeah
yeah yeah I'm a Russian propagandist I'm
a Russian propagandist I've been gassed
twice by your government the government
that pays you so I I think and your
government's done that in the 20th
century before apparently right thanks
thanks so much for your time thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]